Christy is not going after Trump right
now he's going after Ron DeSantis
specifically over January 6. I wasn't
anywhere near Washington that day I have
nothing to do with what happened that
day obviously I didn't enjoy seeing you
know what what happened but we've got to
go forward on this stuff we cannot be
looking backwards and be mired in the
past he talked a little bit before that
about how Biden is running for office
and why he or Biden running and why he
should defeat him but is that the way
you think Republicans should be
answering that question on January the
6th he wasn't anywhere near Washington
did he have a TV Was he alive that day I
mean that's one of the most ridiculous
answers I've heard you don't have an
opinion about January 6th except to say
I didn't particularly enjoy
what happened it's a smart attack for
Christy because Christy's running a kind
of a Kamikaze campaign where he's
theoretically trying to go after Donald
Trump but he knows if he wants to stay
in long enough to go after Trump he's
got to take out Ron DeSantis